un mot sur le nucléaire Frédéric alors
on voit Hervé nous a parlé de ces deux
députés qui font un tour de France du
nucléaire le texte a été un accord en
tout cas a été trouvé hier entre député
en commission mixte donc il devrait être
adopté définitivement la semaine
prochaine par le Parlement qui accélère
la construction des réacteurs nucléaires
il y a un changement de perception de
l'opinion publique sur cette question du
nucléaire clairement oui ça a très
fortement bougé depuis cette crise de
énergie avec le coût le resshérissement
qui pèse fortement sur les ménages
pendant très longtemps on avait une
opinion publique assez flat sur le
nucléaire c'est-à-dire on était sur une
opinion très peu constituée c'est pas un
sujet qui est sur la place publique là
avec cette crise clairement c'est une
enquête il faut JDD du mois de septembre
on en était vraiment au début même au
cœur de cette crise de l'énergie trois
quarts de Français étaient favorables à
la production d'énergie
nucléaire deux tiers contre 51 un an
avant seulement à la production à la
construction de centrale nucléaire et
avec trois dimensions très fortes une
une le nucléaire s'est vu comme
indispensable à la souveraineté à
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
c'est jugé fiable et surtout c'est jugé
bon marché il y a un vrai bouger même
chez sympathisants de gauche on est sur
un 55 ans là-dessus donc on va très bien
que les choses ont fortement évoluées
clairement un effet de contexte même si
je le répète c'est un sujet où je trouve
que l'opinion publique est mis de côté
il n'y a jamais eu un vrai débat dans
les campagnes présidentielles c'est
relativement escamoté et donc l'opinion
publique est très je dirais ballotté par
le contexte très rétive après
Fukushima en 2011 et avec cette crise de
l'énergie désormais très favorable
on va passer à au prochain thème de ce
club on va parler du déplacement
d'Emmanuel Macron hier en
Charente-Maritime alors le chef de
l'État était venu présenter la réforme
du lycée professionnel il a été quelque
peu chahute un comité d'accueil par des
opposants à la réforme des retraites qui
ont brandi des casseroles est-ce que ça
veut dire que le chef de l'État n'arrive
toujours pas à tourner cette page des
réformes des retraites c'est très
compliqué parce que pourquoi elle avait
parlé de lycée professionnel bah
justement pour tenter de mettre quelque
chose d'autre à l'agenda de changer en
réalité de séquence politique et ce
changement de séquence politique
aujourd'hui il est compliqué pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que que
signifie la casserole la casserole c'est
un refus d'entendre c'est une façon de
faire du bruit pour justement et bien
éviter l'interaction avec un chef de
l'État qui souhaiterait vous parler
d'autre chose donc aujourd'hui on va
voir ce qu'il va en être il peut
éventuellement jouer sur les fissures au
sein de l'Inter syndical pour lancer de
nouveaux projets mais il faut voir que
la plupart de ces projets et ses
problèmes fondamental aujourd'hui de
l'exécutif et bien il peut réellement
les lancer tout seul parce qu'il y a
plus de majorité au Parlement parce que
si vous parlez de travail c'est bien
mais il faut un projet loi et ce projet
de loi ça va être compliqué à faire donc
vous attendez que les partenaires
sociaux se mettent d'accord sur un texte
mais le peuvent-ils vraiment de l'autre
côté vous allez lancer d'autres
chantiers mais est-ce qu'il y a une
majorité là évidemment la CMP était
conclusif sur le nucléaire et on
attendait entre guillemets sur les
autres sujets structurants du
quinquennat ce soit dans les 100
prochains jours ou après et bien les
points d'accord ne sont pas tout à fait
évidents on a plutôt au contraire
l'impression d'une
majorité relative non seulement relative
mais en plus en capillotade et donc ce
faisant et bien pour l'exécutif et bien
vous savez on ne détruit vraiment que ce
que l'on remplace et par rapport à la
séquence retraite il y a pas grand chose
justement pour la remplacer d'où cette
répartition des tâches entre ministre et
président de la République qui pour
l'instant ne mène pas grand chose et ne
va pas vraiment à quelque part ça
imprime pas parce que Benjamin me disait
un peu en fait Emmanuel Macron il traite
tous ces sujets il veut parler des
sujets du quotidien il veut revenir au
sujet du quotidien des Français
l'opinion est prête à ça Frédéric pour
l'instant
les Français n'ont pas tourné la page
des retages j'étais très frappé par un
chiffre d'une enquête diffusée hier il
fallait du ciel pour SUD RADIO on
demande aux Français maintenant que la
loi est votée en tout cas que le
processus parlementaire est fini
maintenant qu'elle est validée par le
Conseil constitutionnel et après les
manifestations du 1er mai un baroud
d'honneur peut-être est-ce que les
Français pensent que les manifestations
les mouvements contre la réforme doivent
cesser 55% disent non 55% c'est mes
mobilisations doivent continuer
clairement les Français ne tournent pas
la page et on voit très bien Emmanuel
Macron essayait de sortir de ce court
thermiste conservisme mortifère avec les
100 jours avec le fait qu'il essaye de
prendre la parole sur trois séries de
sujets là en plus il y a un sens caché
il parle aux villes moyennes il parle à
cette France tenté par le vote Le Pen on
avait bien entendu Jordan Bardella
cinglé pendant la réforme des retraites
au début du mois de janvier sur c'est
bac + 2 ok c'est futur bac + 2 auquel
Emmanuel Macron s'est adressé qui vont
payer plein pot la réforme des retraites
il essaye par tous les moyens de
d'orienter de
ces l'agenda des Français mais
aujourd'hui ici et maintenant ça peut
bien sûr changer l'agenda des Français
reste très polarisé d'ailleurs 49 %
expriment un sentiment de révolte sur
leur sentiment à l'égard de la situation
économique sociale l'agenda des Français
reste très marquée par cette réforme des
retraites qui aujourd'hui encore ne
passe pas même si dans les faits elle
est passée et il tente aussi de le faire
via l'agenda parlementaire Quentin oui
il tente de le faire et les événements
n'a présenté mercredi dernier la feuille
de route des 100 jours de l'apaisement
et de l'action du quotidien c'était la
feuille de route qui avait été fixée par
le chef d'État sauf que quand on regarde
après deux mois d'interruption puisque
depuis la réforme des retraites le
Parlement était complètement pétrifiés
depuis deux mois les premiers textes qui
arrivent c'est une loi de programmation
militaire c'est une loi de programmation
de la justice on cherche les sujets du
quotidien dans les prochaines semaines
et on sait aussi les parlementaires nous
le disent ils cherchent la cohérence
c'est-à-dire que il y a beaucoup de
textes de choses patchwork l'industrie
verte la réforme de de Pôle Emploi
qu'est-ce que le 14 juillet lorsqu'on
aura le bilan des 100 jours quel sera le
bilan qu'on pourra tirer sur ces sujets
du quotidien du concret des Français
quel sera le bilan que les gens pourront
voilà afficher très concrètement pour
eux c'est difficile à percevoir alors où
on se parle non parce que je trouve que
pareil des sujets du quotidien sur le
papier c'est un très bonne idée c'est
une manière de montrer que pour lui le
politique change toujours la vie il peut
prendre des sujets de la quotidienneté
il annonce un milliard d'euros une
revalorisation des stages c'est
clairement montrer que la parole
publique la parole du premier homme de
l'état du 1er des Français peut peser
positivement sur le cours des choses et
peut influencer la vie des Français
c'est plutôt bien joué c'est une manière
pour lui de reprendre la main mais
aujourd'hui il est dans une sorte de
corner ou les Français je dirais pas
qu'ils ne l'entendent plus c'est ce que
vous dites Benjamin sur le bruit des
casseroles mais parfois le remède Macron
peut-être pire que le bail parce que la
relation est très en venimée et la
relation c'est très personnalisée on va
aller dans nos enquêtes qualit les
Français disaient c'est lui contre nous
sur la réforme des retraites et donc le
voir c'est le seul qu'on voit de manière
très visible peut je dirais réactiver ce
rejet des Français avec une cote
d'opinion qui est basse mais qui est
très marqué par la part des personnes
qui sont sur un refus épidermique par
exemple les 47 % de très mécontents à
son égard dans lequel JDD il y a une
quinzaine de jours ça veut dire que un
changement de politique limite ni ferait
rien il y a un problème avec la personne
Emmanuel Macron alors il y a un problème
avec potentiellement la politique avec
la personne quelles étaient les grandes
ressources d'Emmanuel Macron si on prend
la crise des gilets jaunes d'abord
lui-même d'abord et avant tout lui-même
son charisme personnel sa capacité à
travers ses autoratoires sa capacité à
retourner l'opinion c'est pas les
violences etc qui retournent l'opinion
je parle ce contrôle de Frédéric au
moment de la crise des gilets jaunes
c'est d'abord et à son essentiellement
lui il grand débat et là on voit qu'en
effet ce verbe magique ne fonctionne
plus et qu'au contraire il est
contre-productif c'est pas la première
fois que ça arrive souvenez-vous
l'itinérance mémorielle juste avant les
gilets jaunes où on ne retient souvent
que les petites phrases et là c'est
peut-être ce qui est en train de se
passer combien même il est écouté
audible ce qui n'est en règle générale
pas le cas et bien souvent c'est
interprété un peu en opposition et
ensuite pour vous sortir d'une crise il
y a pas de remède miracle il y a en
effet des textes et de nouvelles mises à
l'agenda mais le problème c'est que si
on a des textes fourre-tout parce qu'on
a pas de majorité et que quand on essaye
donc de faire des patchwork un peu
improbables de disposition qui pourrait
conquérir une majorité mais de grandes
vision de grandes vision il peut pas
vraiment une avoir parce que vous la
construisez avec qui ou la construisez
avec elle c'est quoi LR aujourd'hui
c'est plusieurs individualités qui se
tirent dans les pattes vous la
construisez avec votre propre majorité
ces trois groupes au sein d'ensemble qui
se tirent également dans les pattes et
pas ça et pense à 2027 donc vous lancez
quelque chose avec une grande vision
dans la machine parlementaire il ressort
quoi bah il ressort peut-être un monstre
un texte que vous n'avez pas tout à fait
envie d'assumer devant l'opinion et ça
évidemment c'est problématique troisième
élément pour arriver à vous en sortir
assez l'argent et évidemment on
distribue quelques milliards mais je
dirais une situation type pompier après
les gilets jaunes ou lors de la crise
covid est difficilement possible comment
est-ce qu'on justifie cette réforme des
retraites on dit bah voilà ça va
permettre de donner c'est pas le
justification officielle mais c'est
quand même l'une des justification
majeure ça permet de donner des gages au
marché et comme ça on va pouvoir
emprunter et on empruntant on va pouvoir
remettre d'aplomb Emmanuel Macron on a
dit clairement nos services publics qui
en ont bien besoin parce qu'on y sous
investi depuis 30 ans le problème c'est
que une fois que vous avez fini cette
réforme des retraites s'y fiches qui est
la plus gentille des agences de notation
commence à vous dégrader et on attend
moodies et ben forcément c'est pas très
très bon qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pour
les services publics demain est-ce que
vraiment pour emprunter à des taux bas
il y a pas de lien direct entre la note
et les taux mais malgré tout il y a
quand même une petite corrélation et ben
c'est problématique donc je crains
malheureusement que pour arriver à
vendre une suite du récit ça soit
compliqué
les Français ne sont pas polarisés par
cette dégradation de la note on sait que
la dette reste plutôt en bas dans les
préoccupations des français même si elle
est remontée et à la progressé dans des
segments conscients de ces sujets on
avait vu à l'époque Sarkozy Fillon
c'est-à-dire les personnes âgées les
sympathisants de droite mais c'est vrai
que cette nouvelle contrainte peut
opérer le récit même si on voit hein
avec les 100 jours avec un président qui
fait feu de toi est-ce qu'il va
actionner le débat sur la fin de vie qui
peut être un moment puisque c'est un
sujet qui implique tout le monde qui
concerne tout le monde qui va pas mettre
de côté à la réforme des retraites mais
qui peut créer un nouvel agenda
de l'inflation du pouvoir d'achat il y a
toute une série de sujets qui pourraient
je dirais désaxer les Français de cette
polarisation sur les retraites mais pour
l'instant aucun ne fonctionne clairement
puisqu'on a cette ce chiffre des
Français qui souhaitent que les
manifestations se pour
entraîne ni sa validation politique ni
son acceptation sociale et crive nous
considérons que nous n'avons pas pu
aller au bout du cheminement
démocratique la suite de la proposition
de loi vise à organiser c'est l'article
2 une grande conférence de financement
sur la pérennité du système de retraite
d'ici à la fin de l'année 2023 alors
est-ce que cette proposition de loi des
chances de passer alors on retrouve en
fait le même clivage que sur la réforme
des retraites avec donc ces députés du
groupe pilote ils sont 20 à l'Assemblée
nationale faut rajouter ceux de la Nupe
les députés RN en fait tout va se jouer
autour DLR on sait qu'il avait manqué 9
voies à la principale motion de censure
l'heure et de l'examen du 49-3 le 20
mars dernier le député LR du Lot que
vous voyez Aurélien Pradier il a déjà
annoncé vouloir voter la proposition de
loi Eliott par cohérence je cite il nous
faudra donc qu'il manque aucune voie à
la majorité présidentielle ce jour-là
surtout que et bien le vote se fait à la
majorité des députés présents en séance
et non pas sur l'ensemble des 577
députés comme sur le 49-3 donc il faut
pas que les députés Renaissance soient
en circonscription ou occupés ailleurs
et on a eu dans l'équipe de Bertrand
pencher qui est donc le président du
groupe pilote avec des gens qui nous ont
dit la logique veut que l'on puisse
gagner ça dépendra de chaque voie
effectivement le son côté le
gouvernement se montre un peu fébrile il
y a forcément un risque parce que nous
sommes dans une majorité relative c'est
ce qu'elle dit lundi soir Olivier du
socle c'était sur elleci donc et bien on
va voir ce qui se passera effectivement
le 8 juin prochain
on envoie aussi des gens qui
s'interrogent est-ce qu'on va aller même
jusqu'au vote autour de cette
proposition de loi pour y avoir des
obstacles une forme d'obstruction de
lapin de la majorité présidentielle
c'est ce qu'on craint d'ailleurs chez
liotte ils en sont capables nous dit-on
chez Bertrand pencher ensuite on verra
aussi la suite du parcours légis si
cette proposition de loi était adoptée a
commencé par le Sénat le Sénat qui a
voté une large majorité de la forme des
retraites on la voit mal adoptée une
abrogation deux mois plus tard mais au
gros pilote on est persuadé que même si
il y a juste un vote favorable de la
proposition de loi à l'Assemblée
nationale et bien le présent implique ne
pourrait plus reculer ne devrait pas
appliquer la réforme des retraites
est-ce qu'elle a une chance de passer
Benjamin cette proposition de la Quentin
le rappeler c'est pas du tout les mêmes
règles que la notion de censure oui
alors elle a une chance de passer aussi
forte que le dernier RIP
pardon maintenant c'est plutôt non
voilà je pense je l'avais dit j'ai
essayé de le dire j'ai essayé de le dire
de façon un peu évasive il y a trois
questions est-ce que ce sera réellement
voté et là en effet il y a deux
obstacles le premier obstacle c'est la
recevabilité financière votre texte une
proposition de loi peut pas créer des
couches supplémentaires pour l'étape ou
les gager et cetera à voir ça passe les
fourches codes de la commission des
finances et derrière la présence de
l'Assemblée alors ça pardon ils disent
qu'ils l'ont fait dans l'article 3 je
crois qu'il y a une taxe sur le tabac il
y a des choses comme ça mais c'est
effectivement quand même que votre
l'attaque sur le tabac ou sur le pétrole
c'est entre guillemets le grand
classique du gage en terme financier
c'est pas sûr non plus que ça passe
parce que évidemment c'est très
hypocrite donc première élément deuxième
élément en effet obstruction ça a déjà
été fait notamment sur la niche la fi il
y a quelques mois donc une niche
parlementaire que les députés de la
majorité présidentielle pourraient
retourner la stratégie LFI contre bien
sûr mais ça a déjà été fait il y a
quelques mois dans la niche les filles
et faut notamment sur le texte corrida
d'Aymeric Caron qui a dû être il faut
bien attendre une niche parlementaire
c'est jusqu'à minuit exactement ça à 9h
le matin et à minuit c'est terminé si le
texte est pas allé au bout on s'arrête
donc si jamais vous êtes assez
intelligent il y a plein d'outils
d'obstruction etc puis qu'en plus vous
allez pas avoir la Conférence des
Présidents tenues par la majorité qui va
donner dans les mains de l'opposition
les moyens de jubiler de l'obstruction
donc il y a des moyens que je sois pas
voté si c'est voter deuxième question
quelles conséquence politique est-ce que
quand même pour le gouvernement ça sent
quelque peu le souffre mais l'objectif
serait d'obtenir une dissolution à la
dissolution avec le repas le problème de
majorité donc ça tendrait la situation
je suis pas sûr que ça nous ferait
sortir de la crise politique et ensuite
est-ce que c'est une chance d'être
adopté à une fine parce que sauf si
Bruno Retailleau se dit du jour au
lendemain la retraite à 72 ans c'est une
bonne idée probable auquel cas si le
Sénat votre compte et bien ça veut dire
que ça c'est Elisabeth borne qui doit se
dire alors je peux donner le dernier mot
à l'Assemblée après avoir donné le 49
alinéa 3 pour avoir la retraite à 64 ans
je vais donner le dernier mois à
l'Assemblée pour qu'elle revienne à 62
ans peu probable également donc sauf à
penser qu'Elisabeth borne Bruno reta
tout d'un coup changerait totalement
d'idées
l'adoption infini de cette réforme
apparaît fort improbable même si en
termes de stabilité politique et de
mobilisation sociale elle peut avoir une
influence est-ce que les Français
ou pas du tout je pense que pour
l'instant ils n'ont que très peu d'idées
sur le contenu de ce que très bien
expliqué il faut qu'ils écoutent notre
ami Quentin également il faut pas avant
lui joindre il y a une nouvelle
mobilisation le 6 juin et on a bien
entendu l'intersyndical dire oui on
laisse du temps entre le 1er mai et tu
vois là on pourra voir si le soutien le
pignon public demeure moi ce qui m'avait
frappé c'est qu'avant le 1er mai dans
toutes nos enquêtes on avait un soutien
qui n'avait pas bougé une soutien et une
sympathie pour le mouvement qui restait
absolument étale par rapport à ce qu'on
mesure au mois de janvier au mois de
février au mois de mars pour l'instant
c'est ça qui est très original après
2010 quand la loi a été votée alors que
les Français c'était beaucoup mobilisés
dans la rue alors que quand même une
petite majorité disait faisons un effort
raisonnable de passer de 60 à 62 ans les
mobilisations avaient fait pshit comme
disait à l'époque Jacques Chirac sur un
autre sur un autre sujet là ce qui est
très intéressant c'est de voir que le
corps social reste absolument tendu
mobilisé par mobiliser en termes de dans
la rue il y avait pas un monde si fort
au mois de mai le 1er mai mais le
soutien se soutient par procuration
reste extrêmement préno mais le 8 mai le
8 juin pour l'instant ça passe au dessus
de la tête de beaucoup de personnes
est-ce que les Français ils sont en
train de se résigner au fait que cette
réforme va finir par passer vous avez vu
les chiffres de enquête Fiducial pour
SUD RADIO elle ne passe pas elle ne
porte pas que sur la réforme mais elle
pense sur la situation économique et
sociale la révolte est beaucoup plus
forte que la résignation la révolte on
est quand même en dessous de ce qu'on
mesurait en novembre 2018 quelques
semaines après le dé avant le
déclenchement du mouvement des gilets
jaunes on était à 60% de mémoire au 58%
de personnes révoltées la résignation on
l'a vu dès le mois de janvier ou dans
toutes nos enquêtes on avait se rejet
très forte de la réforme des retraites
mais pour autant une forme peut-être pas
de résignation mais d'intériorisation
que Macron ne reculerait pas et donc
dans ce cadre là ça n'a absolument pas
bougé mais quand on voit la
personnalisation de la relation avec les
Français le côté très tendu le rejet le
côté repoussoir d'Emmanuel Macron qui
est qui vraiment je dirais fait tâche
dans une partie très importante de
l'opinion publique cette ce qu'on
mesurait depuis ma janvier c'était moins
de la résignation que cette forme de oui
ça passera mais nous restons les
Français restent très mobilisés et
surtout très mécontents et c'est dans ça
que on dit que oui avec l'été ça va
passer au mois de septembre la rentrée
la préparation des Jeux Olympiques il
est tout à fait possible que cette
colère Saône reste pendant une partie
très importante du quinquennat révolter
c'est un terme qui revenait ou certains
que vous vous avez proposé
mais dans les enquêtes qualitatives on
retrouve pas complètement ce mot révolte
mais il y a une vraie colère notamment
moi maintenant sur le contenu de la
réforme je fais référence au Verbatim au
2000 Verbatim du sondage FOB JDD mais
une colère face à la entre guillemets
surdité du chef de qui n'a pas écouté la
rue les manifestations les syndicats les
Français voir ses proches
Benjamin il nous reste 30 secondes ça va
rester un sparadrap en tout cas pour le
moment sur le quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron cette réforme en tout cas
l'opposition va faire que ce soit le cas
et la proposition de loi qu'on doit là
il y en aura d'autres à partir de du 15
avril 2024
du 15 avril 2024 il peut y avoir des
nouvelles tentatives de RIP qu'il a des
chances plus sérieuses au moins d'être
acceptées par le Conseil consuel donc on
peut avoir la collecte des signatures
l'opposition a tout intérêt à rappeler
cette affaire un peu comme l'avait été
pour Nicolas Sarkozy le bouquet fiscal
un peu comme j'irai le fil rouge du
quinquennat évidemment pour le chef
d'État cette copine qui est exactement
avec des propositions de loi dans toutes
les niches etc et donc ça peut être en
effet c'est pas grave capitaine Haddock
et du coup on aura l'occasion d'en
parler le vendredi s'éveille du week-end
on vous emmène à la découverte de notre
pays Mathias sarez nous emmène à Livia
un petit bout d'Espagne au coeur des
Pyrénées-Orientales françaises une
anomalie territoriale vieille de quatre
siècles il vient est une enclave de 1500
habitants riches d'histoire on regarde
c'est un petit bout d'Espagne perché ici
au cœur des Pyrénées Orientales
françaises dans le ciel de Livia le
drapeau catalan flotte pour revenir aux
origines de l'enclave il faut remonter à
1659 à l'époque de Louis XIV lors du
traité des Pyrénées et les Français ont
exigé un passage pour aller du col de la
perche au col du Puymorens donc ils ont
demandé 33 villages pourquoi 33 on ne
sait pas et donc on est à lui on s'est
mis à compter les 33 villages et quand
on est arrivé à Livia les les plis du
potentiel espagnol ont refusé en disant
Livia il y a un document de Charles
Quint qui dit que c'est une ville vous
avez demandé 33 villages il est pas
question de vous donner une ville depuis
l'enclave de 13 km2 est relié à
l'Espagne par une route neutre un axe
traversé par une route nationale bien
française qui mener parfois à quelques
crispations comme personne ne voulait
s'arrêter par fierté nationale il y
avait un accident par jour et un
accident grave par semaine donc on a
essayé de mettre des stops mais le
personne ne vous le mettre un stop sur
sa route donc il y a eu ce qu'on appelle
la guerre des soupes et finalement la
seule solution a donc été de faire un
pont le pont que nous voyons là devant
donc
tu passes au dessus de la nationale 20
et à ce moment-là dont maintenant il n'y
a heureusement plus aucun accident ici
ce qui est quand même une bonne chose
dans ce village de 1500 habitants les
cœurs sont tibériques
ici on mange à l'heure espagnol on vote
pour les élections qui ont lieu de
l'autre côté des Pyrénées un folklore
dont on n'est pas peu fier
plus que la population locale c'est
quelque chose qui interpelle les
visiteurs c'est une curiosité ce qui
fait que parfois on nous rend visite il
y a ici une forme de fierté de faire
partie de Livia je ne pense pas que ce
soit encore lié à l'enclave mais plus
parce qu'historiquement c'est une ville
qui a un poids politique économique dans
la région
l'histoire est partout refuge de
déserteurs pendant la Première Guerre
mondiale point de passage des
républicains espagnols fuyant le
franquisme l'enclave est riche de son
patrimoine
les points forts de la ville sont le
musée son patrimoine architectural c'est
une ville historiquement reconnue dans
le musée nous avons la pharmacie Esteva
qui est l'une des plus anciennes
d'Europe
enclavé mais pas isolé la commune
entretient des rapports étroits avec sa
voisine française et Savard de l'autre
côté du pont et il est un rendez-vous
immanquable chaque année près de quatre
siècles après la signature du traité de
Livia et donc chaque année un début du
mois de juin il y a donc une réunion qui
se fait avec la mairie d'estaval la
mairie de Livia
le corps donc des morceaux de squadres
qui correspond à la police catalane à
l'agaria civil à la police nationale
nos gardes frontières à nous dans les
douaniers pour vérifier que les bornes
sont toujours au même endroit que les 45
bonnes se trouvent toujours au même
endroit une coopération qui pour leur
reste du domaine culturel et consult
Atif pour des questions de gestion des
forêts ou de commémorations mais à
l'avenir les deux communes aimeraient
être une politique territoriale
transfrontalière en cohérence pour
éviter des imbrogliaux sur des normes
environnementales de sécheresse ou de
gestion de la pandémie du coronavirus
[Musique]
voilà pour ce reportage la semaine
prochaine on vous emmène à Armentières
voir la renaissance d'une brasserie
familiale vous verrez tout ça d'abord
Quentin on regarde ce qu'elle a une de
nos quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]
et on revient sur le déplacement
d'Emmanuel Macron en Charente-Maritime à
la Une de plusieurs quotidiens
exactement à l'image de la Charente
Libre à Angoulême Macron à Sainte
accords et désaccord ou encore Le
Télégramme Macron le Paris jeune dans le
1er journal on lit la difficulté pour le
chef de l'État et être audible sur la
réforme de l'enseignement Rochelle on en
parlait il y a un instant avec les clubs
le titre revient aussi en longueur sur
la mobilisation hier encore contre la
réforme des retraites en marge de
déplacement ils étaient plusieurs
centaines à l'attendre des 8 heures sur
un parking joint de la casserole et du
champ révolutionnaire écrit la Charente
Libre la CGT enedis a aussi essayé de
couper le courant dans le lycée où se
trouve Émilie Macron mais patatra les
lisait avait prévu un groupe électrogène
pour assurer la sonorisation du discours
du chef de l'État si je suis bien
entretien exclusif avec le chef de
l'État voilà retrouver le goût de
l'avenir si tu en exergue le journal de
Bordeaux vous le voyez interview de
Jefferson décor que l'on connaît bien
sur Public Sénat il vient aussi dans ce
club dans cette interview et bien
Emmanuel Macron assume la réforme des
retraites je fais le choix du sérieux du
travail de la réindustrialisation comme
je l'avais annoncé pendant la campagne
présidentielle est-il plus loin dans
l'interview Emmanuel Macron dit vouloir
retrouver un esprit de concorde et un
certain goût de l'avenir il faut
retrouver de la Concorde pour l'ambition
du pays dit-il la sécheresse dans le
pays fait la Une encore une fois
effectivement ce matin on voit que en
Isère il y a du mieux mais titre le
Dauphiné du mieux ce sont les dernières
pluies mais avec des disparités dans le
département la Provence à Marseille qui
écrit nous ne sommes que le 5 mai mais
la région est déjà en alerte un mot sur
un succès
voilà la saison touristique dans
l'Allier démarre fort dit la montagne
dans son édition effectivement de
Moulins depuis le covid on voit un
besoin des Français d'aller s'oxygéner à
la campagne et l'année 2003 s'annonce
encore meilleur effectivement d'ailleurs
ça tombe bien on est à la veille un
week-end de trois jours on souhaite de
pouvoir aller vous aérer ce que vous
allez faire Quentin
[Musique]
mission notre nouvelle plateforme public
sénat.fr on se retrouve lundi mardi et
on vous souhaite un très bon weekend
[Musique]